heaven I know you go back to working
with Quentin Tarantino for kill bill one
and two we just want to find out first
how did you book your job as a makeup
department head for those two films I
it's kind of a funny story because I
Matt Quentin through a friend of mine
Julie Dreyfuss who has been in a couple
of his movies and she we went to the set
of Jackie Brown and I had just had a
baby then I wasn't working or anything
but we went on set and I was like oh my
god this is like a night shoot and
hermosa beach and everybody's having a
blast and I told him I said you know I
haven't had so much fun on a set since I
worked with David Lynch you made me want
to do movies again and I said I want to
work on a next movie whether I'm
sweeping floor or do whatever so six
years later he called me and he said you
know you said this which I didn't
remember but he remembers everything and
he said you know I want to you don't
have to sweep the force for me but I
would love you to department head it and
that's how I did it I'm wondering how
does the makeup department had differ
from a key makeup artist what is the
difference in duties and
responsibilities um I think that's sort
of individual I mean I think there are
some like general rules and but they
also keep changing the title now it's
not called key makeup anymore it's
called assistant department head and and
i think that i think that you know i do
it differently with every film i do just
kind of what the needs are who I'm
taking care of their just your backbone
basically they're you know your right
hand and and I'm more of a beauty makeup
artist greg funk who usually works as
Mikey he's he is one of the few people
who are both good with beauty as well as
effects and and he sometimes works
for can be effects company is that
always does Quentin's films so he was
kind of the obvious choice to bring on
you know that he also helped Jay Garber
on set with like the frosted man which
were originally dummies but cuenta
didn't like the way they moved so he
picked three people from the crew and
made them into the dead man not Sam
Jackson is sitting on and then ever
thrown up on a stagecoach so so
basically you know I tried to cover
myself with you know I always hire
somebody was really good with with
effects to kind of back me up on that
that end of it like I can do some of it
but you know he's a lot better so why
not have somebody else who really enjoys
it and so you know sometimes they do
continuity photos or continuity book and
it's just you know when your department
had you design ad work with the director
but he works more with me he's not in
the production meetings and stuff I was
getting more of the information just for
me so that's kind of the general of it I
think from your website you had a
statement that just said you want to
show that make up not only beautifies
characters but completes them I thought
that was wonderfully put how so how was
that the case you know you sometimes
have to do just like really saddle
things because you're just with the
actor and you're working with them of
course you have information like for
example with Quentin who is very
specific how he wants people to look it
doesn't tell me how to do it but he
knows what he wants them to look like
and when I you know and then I get the
actor in a chair and they might have
some different ideas you know and it's
you're just kind of merging that and and
making everybody happy and you know and
it's like when you're going through the
character with thee and going through
the emotions with the actor
what he's doing that day and it's like
you can do just really minimum thing
that they know you're doing and and you
know and it helps them do you know or be
the character and do what they want to
do and and you know and it's like nobody
else is ever gonna see it but it's just
kind of like you know it's there they
know it's there and it just helps and
completing what they're doing and you
know and it's like wardrobe comes in
before me and that's all set you know to
three months before I get on the movie
to prep and you know and I can I have to
work like with Kourtney what she's doing
I can't come up with like some you know
40s make up with the 1800s film you know
so it's like you always have to follow
with what's already there established
sure are you using um contouring and
shadowing on every character with sits
in the makeup chair or is that only to
really more for beautification we did
some of it not a lot on this one but we
were kind of weathering the men just
making them kind of ready and and you
know whether then exposed we used like
we had alcohol paint and such so we used
a little bit of that to sort of secretly
contour or highlight you know we wanted
the cheek when I wanted strong
cheekbones and I grew up watching
westerns and I always remember when it
was a little girl and would see Clint
Eastwood with kind of a tan skin and the
white you know squiggly lines around his
eyes and I wanted that you know I wanted
a little texture without it looking like
we were doing anything and you know we
would highlight a little bit around the
eyes just to make it pop up a little bit
but we didn't use any really
beautification but we just want to kind
of make stronger what was already there
what do you love most about your job you
say that you have already the costume
people have already determined that so
then they're coming to you sitting in
your chair what do you love most about
it i I just I loved everything about it
I you know especially on hateful eight
we were getting up like at 3-330 in the
morning and it would such a great group
of people and the actors is showing up
early so they can have a coffee together
outside our room and we would hear
Kurt's laughter come down like echoing
in the mountains you know and there was
never like oh the alarm is going off it
was just fun like everything about it
and it's such a team mark I love that I
love working with people I love people I
yeah I don't know that I just love
everything about it not just my job but
just being there seeing it and you know
when when I grew up I didn't even know
there was a job called makeup artist so
that wasn't something that you'd
formally trained for you sort of just
fell into it or I I met a girl here I
was out here as like I was an au pair
and in LA and I met her Icelandic girl
who was going to a makeup school here
and I was just like oh wow like I would
love to do that and so I went back to
Iceland and I was just like this is just
what I want to do I want to do it how do
and just figure out how I could go back
here and go to that school so I did have
a training I did go to the school and
went through that whole program but and
just started working I started doing
craft service when I was you know going
to school just to get to know people and
I'm still friends with a lot of the
people i met back then and and so we've
kind of grown up together in the hateful
eight Jennifer Jason Leigh it's it's
certainly a lot of wounds that she's
wearing and and and are you doing that
part or is the special effects person
special effects makeup Jake Garber 4km
be
he was the onset person and took care of
that Jennifer would come first my chair
and we would do skin care and and a
little highlighting and such and then
she would go and with Jake and he would
ruin everything I did yeah I couldn't
have I just was like time had stood
still I have seen her in so many film
right she still is just to me she could
be 22 years old and her character had a
very youthful attitude as well so I just
marveled at the fact that how time had
just seemed to stood still when I wanted
her she's just so amazing I mean she
just immersed herself in it and she was
there and like you know 28 degree you
know below and you know only breath you
see in the movie that's all real that's
not you know we were freezing and when
when the weather was kind of one in
milder side we were inside and when I
was blizzard we were outside shooting so
it was but it made us all like family
you know so what would normally in la
you're working with blotting people and
they're sweating and they're shiny but
in those elements where you said or
maybe someone else has said 10 degrees
was was above you know was the norm when
the Sun was out right so what kind of
damage control or things are you doing
to help we definitely put a lot of
research into skincare makeup the desert
freeze that can stand the weather we had
insulated bags to carry our makeup and
and and my team we all had to be
prepared to jump on anyone's actors and
and do continuity and do what needed to
be done because you know you never knew
who was down below at base camp like you
know for car rides away then you on a
mountain top so we were always all
prepared to jump in and do what needed
to be done and Quentin it or not just on
this one but in general he's very much
out of care
right here right now kind of like oh I
want like a scar and then Jake it's just
like okay I'm okay yeah and he's you
know he's very spontaneous in in some
ways and where he's very sad with other
ways like Kurt Russell's rushed us was
definitely written into the script so he
started growing not right away and it
was it was all his and we had to fill in
the color a little bit because because
of lighting purposes more than anything
else and you know and he was wearing the
big gorgeous Buffalo code that Courtney
designed and you know and the caller
would kind of rub the collars off so we
were just kind of touching up a little
bit but basically what we did we made it
so it would stay that we didn't have to
be going in every take and fixing there
was mostly the teeth that we had to keep
up because you know you can't make them
all look greedy and then like white
shiny teeth so mmm that was a challenge
keeping that up because they're all
drinking hot drinks will not help
keeping it on they were eating stew for
days and and and you know and just like
30 minute take so it's you know it's
bound to wear off a little bit sure sure
how do you know when a character is
ready then you sit them down and and how
do you know that they're they're ready
to go out there and then you take the
photo make sure for continuity purposes
um well we it's all time to a minute so
like when I come in in the morning you
know you have your saturday then you get
your afternoon chair and you have X
amount of time to do it and which is
kind of worked out beforehand and I just
said us need it but you were always you
know down to sometimes seconds you know
with the actors when the need to be
ready so it's like I better be ready and
the actor better be ready
and you know and it's depends on the
actor you know some people need a little
time to to get into the character than
either you know little moment in the
morning and stuff whether that's in the
makeup chair hair or in their trailer
you know it just depends it different
with everybody right and lastly when
you're applying makeup for a camera
versus just somebody wearing something
out to an event whether a day or night
how much heavier and and different types
of products to make it really pop on
screen it's a it's an interesting
question because in some ways is not
that different and and because usually
like if you're doing like a red carpet
thing it needs built to last ray and but
you're doing more of a beauty thing
maybe than a character thing and a lot
of actresses when they go out on red
carpet there themselves whereas you know
when i'm doing them from film then
they're a character yeah so when you
when they're going on the red carpet as
themselves they sometimes want more
makeup because we maybe need a little
bit of a mask because they're kind of
representing themselves but they you
know you can't get into their soul you
know that yeah red hot red carpets are
tough yeah a lot of people coming at you
a lot of chaos yeah not that I've been
in front of the camera but from behind
yeah yeah no certainly in is right so so
you said the difference isn't too much
in terms of the heavy application and
just making it stay yeah it's it's just
a longevity over that you can't go with
them and touch up all the time and you
know so it's um you know beauty on
camera versus that you know I'm working
more you know with with lighting and you
know working with somebody like Bob
Richardson it's just dream so I really
don't have to worry about anybody that I
put
in front of his lens you know he's just
amazing with the lighting and whereas if
I'm sending somebody down the red carpet
you need a little bit more contouring
and such because you know the flashes
just you know wash you out and side so
right and shadowing in there interesting